bouge pas pendant le single
battus bush non là je suis d'accord
c'est google c'est ça qui m'énerve je
suis en train de chercher un nom pour
l'association belge sait pas c'est un
trek on les balance c'est à dire que il
ya un moment donné mais ballan et exige
beaucoup et un moment donné elles ont
décidé et alors il a plu c'est très très
bas là aussi vous dis cela je vous dise
tellement changeant j'en sais rien comme
7,1 à mon avis j'essaye tous les signes
aides en fonction de leurs biens jean
millaire donc interview psy est ce que
vous êtes mito cédér mythomane
oui et on gérera un menu de pâques c'est
pas de la bonne foi je vous êtes mis
torse au sens courant de l'acceptation
du terme
non mais pas mythomane est ce que vous
êtes schizo toujours au sens courant du
terme
bah oui non donc j'ai pas dire non à
chaque fois non plus non mais je vous
répond sincèrement ce resort non ya pas
deux gérard miller n'ont pas eu cette
parano pas du tout je vais de mazo nom
n'est pas qu'on fasse un peu mal non ah
bon
essayez à non mais moi je fais pas
l'amour à une annonce car c'est
seulement dans l'amour qu'ont fait mal à
blake canton et maggio sedan l'amour que
ça non seulement n'ont pas sûr non pas
seulement parce que vous êtes en leur
genre et pas aux beautés aussi
massivement jacques chirac
on a 95 e s que vous êtes sado pas du
tout non plus je rigolais sado-maso pas
du tout exhibo alors vraiment pour vous
donner un oui à mon âge non mais
attendez je vais la télévision non vous
promener à poil devant votre fenêtre on
se chambre voisine vous regarde donc là
c'est un sens plus exacte du terme
d'exhibition alors pas du tout pas du
tout non vous balader jamais par exemple
sur la plage avec un slip boulboul
non est ce que vous êtes cassettes
pornos cassettes pornos non il y avait
un des deux termes où j'aurais pu
répondre oui mais pas la sellette phone
est ce que vous êtes gérant taux pas du
tout non j'ai eu pas les vieilles pas au
sens au sens de l'amour au sens une
force physique
oui j'aime bien les vieux oui plutôt et
n'est pas aussi dangereux non non non je
vous ai depuis d'entrée un peu ton sur
ton quand on vieillit ça devient nul
c'est vrai voyez plutôt pédo alors non
plus parce que feydeau c'est en dessous
de la loi et de la tolérance humaine non
non pas du tout je ne veux le droit j'ai
rajouté de la loi et de la tolérance
humaine marion noir non c est de la
tolérance humaine c'est à dire je suis
pour qu'à certains moments la loi
coïncide avec cette idée qu'on se fait
de l'humanité est ce que vous êtes jo je
vous auront moi je sais plus trop tard
vous n'êtes pas doué pour que les gens
répondent oui pourquoi moi parce que je
réponde non y'en a qui m'ont jamais
besoin d'eux m'a dit oui là je vais vous
dire franchement j'espère si chaud non
fétiche au nom travelo prêché non mais
c'est amusant c'est que finalement votre
idée de l'interview psy c'est un
interview qui se situe entièrement du
côté de la perversion fleurs youtube
arabe
oui non c'est pas parce que je veux que
vous sachiez c'est que de tous les
patientes les psychanalystes voix se
noie quasiment jamais c'est lé pervers
la mer masochiste jamais un
exhibitionniste quasi jamais devient
voir un psychanalyste pourquoi parce
qu'il sait parfaitement quel est son
objet de jouissance il n'a pas besoin de
s'allonger sur un divan pour savoir ce
qu'il a besoin ce dont il a besoin
je faisais de disques au disco
oh maintenant j'accueille quelqu'un qui
va vous intéresser puisque j'étais
ministre de la coopération